[Music]
over 60 million people are under a
winter storm watch right now
and winter can be a tough time of year
for anyone
i think about my isolated producers in
their apartments
in new york covering this pandemic and
we all feel it's important now more than
ever
to bring awareness to mental health
issues kicked up over the last nine
months
this week we saw the first sign of hope
with vaccines
but most of the news lately has been
pretty grim
but i always try to remain hopeful
and that is why this segment is so
important to me because i suspect
it's been hard for you too and you're
trying to hold on to just a little bit
of hope
according to the centers for disease
control and prevention this june
there were triple the number of people
who showed symptoms of anxiety
than there were in 2019 and there were
four times more people
who reported having depression if people
heed the advice
of medical professionals they will be
staying home and celebrating the
holidays
without their friends and without their
family members
so how do we make it through these
coming months and weeks
without feeling mental distress or
isolation
and joining me now to discuss is tony
and emmy award-winning actor
courtney b vance and psychologist dr
robin smith
who was known as the therapist in
residence on the oprah winfrey show
thank you so much for being here you
courtney i want to start with you you
have been outspoken
about mental health issues why are you
personally
so passionate about this issue
oh i i think we i think we're having an
issue
uh with your audio so let me go to dr
smith while we get
that fixed dr smith i want to ask you um
a question i posed earlier
uh how do how do we make it through the
coming weeks and months without
feeling depressed or isolated i know
that when you're not able to see your
friends and hug
them and see your family it can feel
very isolating how do you
uh cope uh since you can't see people
yeah you know and thank you i'm glad to
be here and
the question is so important when you
said
you know how do we not feel and you
didn't say
the word despair but how do we not feel
despair
i might caution us to not set the bar
so high and in some ways unrealistically
it's not how do i not feel despair it's
not you know how do you
not feel down and depressed and lonely
it's how do you manage your loneliness
what do we do with it and so you know
zerlina part of what
uh the challenge is here is how do we
surround ourselves with our tribe and
not physically and
how do we connect with people i mean
look i have never
done more work and more connecting like
i am with you and your audience right
now
uh like i do with courtney i'd much
rather be with him in person but we
can't do that and so
the challenge is how do we create
community and nurture ourselves in the
face of
being lonely not trying to avoid it
in terms of uh you know the difference
with being
just anxious um and there actually being
something
chemically um that needs to be addressed
how are people supposed to identify the
distinction there i think a lot of
people
a lot more people during pandemic are
feeling these these feelings in a way
that they may not have before
because of the change in circumstances
but how are they able to make the
distinction between
you know normal levels of stress and
anxiety
as a result of living through a pandemic
and trying to survive a pandemic
uh and they're you know they're needing
to be some sort of professional
attention because of a depressive
disorder
um or or sad which is something that um
sad which is something that happens in
the winter months yes seasonal affective
disorder
not enough light not enough sun
you know one of the things i would
invite everyone to do
is don't try and diagnose yourself
uh you know every time we i don't know
about you
but i know the people in my patients and
people i'm coaching that i'm talking
with
you know you get a sniffle and you think
oh my goodness i've got
you know covered 19. uh the same thing
is true
with anxiety and depression there are
times in which we think
oh i'm so lonely i'm so depressed
i feel hopeless maybe i need
medication what i would say is that's
possible
but no one has escaped this pandemic
without being hit hard emotionally
if you think that something is different
in a way that is more than the pandemic
something that
is shaking you and courtney in a few
moments we'll talk about
um some of the things that showed up in
his own family around depression
and around suicide that's when you want
to seek out professional help
you want to call a hotline a lifeline
you want to reach out and make sure that
you don't remain
isolated because that's where we really
get in trouble
oh i think we have courtney's sound um
there so i hope that
you can hear me and that we can hear you
um but
i i my question was why did you
choose mental health as an issue that
you wanted to target your efforts at
um you're very passionate about this
issue
because it affected me directly can you
hear me
no because it affected me directly my
father
uh killed himself when i was about
30 doing six degrees of separation on
broadway
top of the world in the theater world
and um
my uh my world crashed and
when when you get into in the midst of a
crisis
either you can go up or down you can
uh um attack it head-on
or you can run from it and my mother
pulled my sister and i aside and we were
after we had spent a month down there
helping her organize
the house and uh she said i want you
both
to go into uh therapy in your respective
cities and i'm gonna do the same here in
detroit
and we're gonna fight for our lives and
for our family and
um that that that's what basically
it's a fight life is a fight life is a
battle
life is a journey it's a marathon it's
not a sprint somebody comes into
to to to you know we think that the
first sign of trouble and what
what did what did our grandparents have
great grandparents
and great-great-grandparents who
everything was a no what did
how dare marion anderson think that she
could become an opera singer how dare
ralph bunch
dream of being a diplomat what is what's
wrong with them what is wrong with us
the first sign of somebody giving us a
no we
fold no we're not going nowhere i don't
care how bad it looks
i don't know how bad it gets i don't
care what fool is in the white house
we're not going nowhere we know what we
know we've been through too much we've
we've marched we've been bitten by dogs
we've gone through slavery we've been
with everything that they've thrown at
us we have risen
and yet and still we rise maya angelou
we got so much to it we just
get on the internet and look up our
people who we are what we've done where
we come from
i'm not going nowhere i don't care if my
father killed himself
i'm going forward he wasn't able to do
it i know he want me to do it and just
because somebody is having struggle
doesn't mean this
there's no shame in it they're
struggling we all struggle we're all
struggling especially today
in the midst of all this madness being
thrown at this country at this world
we're all struggling so get put up put
on your big board
pants and your big girl pants and let's
go let's go
yeah in terms of last question here
because we only have one more minute
um but what's your message for people
who are going through that emotional
rollercoaster and during this pandemic
just fight it out is that your message
for them
you know find somebody find their
support system find somebody that that
that
that is the fight sometimes the fight is
is admitting that you've got to take a
step back and get some help
sometimes the fight is standing up and
going toe-to-toe or whatever sometimes
it is
taking a step back and and and going
into a cave
go ahead miss miss dr robin well you
know
and just in these last uh moments thank
you courtney for that fire and wisdom
uh because honestly that the
what will save a life is that we break
the silence and the stigma of shame
that we make sure that people who are
listening today
know that all people suffer and that you
can redefine your suffering and pain
absolutely thank you so much i'm sorry
we ran